hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video guys i
would like to go through everything that
is happening on the option market on amc
and gamestop because we have a huge huge
expiry coming and i want to show you
what you guys can do with the 145 strike
if you have some that expire in order to
roll it but maybe in a smart way so
let's get into it
[Music]
okay guys first let's have a look at amc
option expiry okay so amc
alright guys so bam it's computing
look at that yes it's beautiful it's
everything is automated
and i can have all the information i
want about the option market
once again yes i was an option trader
for seven years so i know a bit uh how
this is working
so here what information do we have okay
first information is that uh there is a
lot of options on amc
there is a five percent of synthetic
short right now it can go up to 23 if
all the options and the money uh the
total short interest is 18 so it's
roughly stable the dtc is at 1.85 so
it's not very big because it's going to
get bigger on the upside
but it's still important
and what is very interesting is look at
this huge option expiry 70 million
equivalent shares the shareholder is a
50 million
sets around 12
of the share float right
yeah something like this 12 of the share
float are gonna expire on january so
where are these options coming from uh
mostly the fully strike and look for the
greens guys 40 strike
is big 20 strike is big is big the 10 is
not big so 20 30 right and on the puts
we have some as well yes of course on
the puts we have more
on the 10 strike which is huge guys so
we have a bit of it everywhere and what
is interesting is that you can just look
at that so i computed the p l of all
this options so this is how you find the
max pay so when you take all the open
interest okay and you check the payoff
of all the options available in the
market you're gonna come up with this
chart all right so you can see the
minimum level is around 22 23 right now
it was 27 before it was it's now 22 23
so this is the maximum pain all right so
this is
what price market makers would like amc
to close on the expiry so that they
minimize the profits of investors that
bought this options put or calls and so
it's better for them the truth is that
they don't i think have really they
cannot decide where amc would go but
what is for sure is that whatever the
price is going to get closer to this
level right you can see the gamma i'm
always talking about gamma so
there is something very easy i wanted to
show you guys here that you can
understand the gamma is the convexity so
it's the curvature of this curve and you
can see that the gamma is maximum here
it's where the curvature is at its
maximum all right so basically and the
more gamma
the more likely
the moves are going to be amplified and
the closer we get to the expiry the
bigger the gamma so to conclude on what
this means it means that whenever we're
gonna go through 21 22 all the strikes
close to the expiry the moves are gonna
get huge and probably as often we're
gonna end up at 22 23 on the 21st of
january that's what it means but we're
gonna have a lot of volatility coming uh
this days you can refer to the analysis
i did yesterday on amc but for now you
can already see for example uh when we
had a strong move down like this here we
went through the 22 level and this is
why this move was so big all right if we
go on the other side it's going to be
the same on this day we did a 10 10
move the gamma is 1.7
i compute the gamma you see as you can
see here we have right now 20 million
thousand gamma across calls and puts we
have 8 million on the calls and we have
nine million underputs so 17 million of
gamma so
as a percentage of the daily volume is
1.7
so for example if we move by 10
it means that option market makers need
to trade 17
of the daily volume of the average daily
volume okay so it's a lot and the closer
we get to the expiry the bigger it's
gonna be okay so that's what i wanted to
show you guys about this expiry there is
nothing more we can really say about
that okay now for those who have the 145
strike because it's huge guys it's
really huge it's the biggest strike that
we have on this expiry look we have 70
million shares and 145 strikes 20
million shares are coming from only this
strike so
a lot of you must have it and you are
wondering what to do with it and i'm
gonna give you an answer guys the best
thing to do
for me so i personally didn't buy this
track because the more like to buy very
out of the money strikes right now you
can roll it to jan 23 for example
because the volatility is quite low it's
120 right now it was 170 for example six
months ago so look at the difference in
price so right now one option like this
costs 200 us dollars but if the
volatility is higher by 40 percent so
170 like it was the price doubles all
right so six months ago this was twice
more expensive than now so maybe it's a
good opportunity now to go to the gym 23
stride because the spot is low and the
volatility is low so it's the right time
probably to buy it now the better things
to do which i would probably do
is actually because as you guys go check
the analysis i did yesterday on amc i
think that the squeeze will happen maybe
you know we need at least two or three
months alright so maybe april maybe june
maybe even later okay i don't know but i
don't think it's gonna happen before
march so in this situation the good
thing to do guys is to buy i prefer to
buy a lower strike so for example you go
to jan 23 and you buy a 60 strike so
okay it costs more expensive
that's true okay maybe 60 is too too low
but let's go to 80 strike
so you're gonna pay for that 600 us
dollar but you make it cheaper because
you sell the march 80 strike because you
are saying we're gonna go above 80 in
gen 23 but not before march so you do a
cold calendar all right so you buy
gen 23 80 strike you sell march 22 80
strike right so that you reduce the
premium of your strike and you can do
that with the 95 strike as well because
it's the biggest strike on march and if
you do that here oh sorry let me do that
again so now let's start with the 95
strike so if you go with a 95 strike the
price is 217 but you can reduce that to
235
by selling the march 95 call and look
what happens if amc goes they're not
like 300 for example right now you still
make a lot of money right because your
230 dollars are gonna transform in uh
one thousand dollars so it's still a
very bullish position but you just make
your program cheaper by saying
it's not going to happen before march
and i think it's the right time to buy
jan because it's cheap if amc start by
moving by fifty percent up the jump to
me three volatility will go much higher
so it's better to get it now but make it
cheaper by selling march for example 22
on the same strike don't sell more than
you have if you buy one gen 23 you sell
one march 22 and it's basically reducing
your premium by
15 20
okay depending on which strike you do it
if you do it on the lowest strike on an
80 strike i think 60 is the best to be
honest i think this is the best position
to get guys uh this is what i would
probably propose on my discord i still
need to think a little bit about it but
i think that buying a gen 2360 strike
call and reducing its premium by selling
the march 22 60 strike is a very good
strategy okay instead of paying 400 us
dollars you pay only 320 us dollars and
whenever there is a squeeze guys this is
going to go of course crazy let's take
takes 1 000
so you still make money right if this
quiz happens before march 22 but the
thing is that it should happen after so
if it happens after
then as you can see bam you make
15 000 u.s dollars right but of course
if it happens before you're gonna be
very disappointed so this is the risk
but i think it's a good risk to take at
this moment so that's it for me guys i
hope you enjoyed this video i just
wanted to show you how you can reduce
your premium by buying some cool
calendars that i showed you here so if
you did enjoy this video please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so that you're going to be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys